war
learn more about fort worth all weekend
here on american history tv
[Applause]
jim wright
governor
senator yarbrough
mr vodka
ladies and gentlemen
there are no faint hearts in fort worth
and i appreciate
i appreciate your being here this
morning hi
this mrs kennedy is
organizing herself it takes longer
but of course she looks better than we
do when she does it
but we appreciate your welcome
this city has been a great western city
the defense of the west cattle oil and
all the rest
it has believed and strengthened this
city
and strengthen this state
and strengthen this country
what we're trying to do in this country
and what we're trying to do around the
world
i believe is quite simple
and that is to build a military
structure which will defend the vital
interests of the united states and in
that great cause fort worth
as it did in world war ii
as it did in developing the best bomber
system in the world the b-58
and as it will now do in developing the
best fighter system in the world the tfx
fort worth will play its proper part
[Applause]
we're here at the corner of 8th street
in maine in downtown fort worth and it
wasn't but a couple of yards from this
spot that on november 22 1963
john f kennedy gave
the first of his last two public
speeches it was a cold wet day
that morning he got in late at night he
flew into the carswell base just a
couple of hours away and when he flew
over the city
all of the buildings were outlined in
white lights some of the civic leaders
at that time wanted to welcome the
president even before he landed and even
today that's part of the tradition of
fort worth if you see our skyline at
night the larger more prominent
buildings are still outlined in in white
lights we've kept that alive
so he arrived at the hilton hotel behind
me
very late at night he and mrs kennedy
were tired uh they went to bed
and
when they got up the next morning a very
large crowd hundreds of people assembled
right here in what used to be a a
parking lot
and
the democratic
operatives at the time and and speaker
jim wright had arranged for a a flatbed
truck and microphones to be pulled into
the parking lot so that the president
could step out to see the folks and
address the crowd that had that had
assembled on the parking lot they didn't
know that there was going to be a speech
they just showed up hoping to see him
come out of the hotel and and for the
motorcade to leave
so the president comes out with speaker
wright and a number of other dignitaries
and he gives the first of his last two
public speeches right here thirdly for
the united states
to fulfill its obligations around the
world
requires that the united states move
forward economically
that the people of this country
participate in rising prosperity and it
is a fact in 1962
and the first six months of 1963
the economy of the united states grew
not only faster
than nearly every western country which
had not been true in the fifties but
also grew faster than the soviet union
itself that's the kind of strength
united states needs economically in
space militarily
and in the final analysis that strength
depends upon the willingness of the
citizens of the united states
to assume the burdens of leadership
i know one place where they are
here in this reign in fort worth in
texas in the united states we're going
forward thank you
and he talked about
um
leadership in space he talked about
leadership in the world he talked about
american ambitions both here and abroad
uh he talked about education and the
importance of that
and it was a very inspirational speech
even though it was cold and rainy and
people were holding newspapers over
their heads uh and he was received very
warmly and they left the
podium
went back into the hotel and just an
hour or so later
they attended the
chamber of commerce breakfast that was
in the ballroom in the hotel
i i think that the ticket price was two
dollars and fifty cents to see the
president of the united states and the
first lady on that morning you gotta
remember that this was a campaign swing
uh there had been some fractures in
texas democratic politics and
he and vice president johnson
were on this swing to try to knit
together the factions of the democratic
party so this was very much a political
stopover
and uh and at the chamber of commerce
speech he talked about fort worth and
our role in aviation history uh the new
bomber that had just been approved for
construction here and mind you
america was at war at that time and and
we were very concerned about uh what was
going on around the world uh both nearby
uh off the coast of florida and in
russia and the and the middle east so
national security was very much top of
mind and the bomber that was going to be
built here in fort worth was very
important and that was a an opportunity
to talk about
the united states's
role in international affairs and fort
worth's role in national security so a
lot of the speech was was based on that
and uh and it was very uplifting and
inspirational and it was it was very
funny you know the president was a very
charming fellow
and uh and
jackie kennedy
came a little bit late i'm not sure that
she was feeling that well in the morning
but she
she did she did show up and the crowd it
seems the stories that i've heard
are that the crowd was just as excited
to see her as to see him
and so that was kind of a special moment
in fort worth
everybody was excited now while that was
going on in the hotel
people were lining up on the streets we
knew where the motorcade was going to be
high school bands and cheerleaders were
lining the streets uh folks knew when
the motorcade was going to go by so the
office building started emptying the
department stores started emptying and
the motorcade when it finally did come
off of the hotel property and onto main
street motorcade went down toward the
courthouse and he left fort worth
on a high people were cheering and
waving and the bands were playing and
the cheerleaders were doing their thing
and
and the stories that i have heard after
the fact uh are that
um are that people were very proud that
fort worth hosted
the president of the united states and
the first lady and they were very glad
that they had an opportunity to see them
in person and to and to host them in
such fine fashion
one of the one of the things that a lot
of people don't know about what fort
worth did in preparation for that event
was that some of the local families with
extensive art collections that are now
in museums
loaned
monets and degas and renoise and
original paintings and sculpture to
decorate their room in the hilton hotel
and when they got there that night
they didn't take note of it a little
brochure had been printed
that described what was hanging on the
walls and sitting on the coffee table
listing the artist and the date painted
and the donor
and that morning jackie kennedy noticed
that little brochure that was left on
the table
and
supposedly told the president
did did you know these are all real
so it was kind of a kind of a neat touch
that that fort worth delivered on that
on that morning
so they leave fort worth they go back to
cars well they're going to fly the 50
miles between dallas and fort worth
and uh and they land in fort they land
in dallas now the sun is shining the
skies have opened up
the day is fantastic fort worth is on a
high
and of course we know what happened in
dallas
you know touching a day
like november 22nd
1963
you don't do that lightly
and
we knew that it had to be done the right
way had to be done sensitively
but one of the stops that we knew we had
to make was in dallas
and who tell the jfk dallas story
so well and so respectfully
and
how we could tell this story differently
and respectfully and augment
the rest of the day
tell our
our morning story the way they tell the
the rest of the day story so
part of the process of developing this
tribute
was reaching out to the kennedy family
and letting them know that we were going
to do it and we found avenues and folks
who had relationships with the kennedys
and
and had correspondence with caroline
kennedy who
was very appreciative
of uh of of this work
we worked with the architect who
designed the kennedy tribute in boston
and
uh and so that was a that was a good
connection as well
none of the kennedys attended the
ribbon cutting for the event but
caroline did send a very gracious letter
that was read that morning i had the
privilege of reading that letter
and and we were very proud to know that
that we had touched her and that the
family recognized what we were trying to
accomplish here in fort worth
carved in the in the water wall
is a phrase that we found during the
development process during the storyline
creation process
a man may die nations may rise and fall
but an idea lives on and that quote
resonated with us it seemed like that
was what we were trying to say
uh it was more of a it's more than the
story of a visit
it's about the power of ideas and how
ideas can live
a life all of their own and if they're
really good ideas they'll live a very
long time and they never die and
and they adapt so we chose to highlight
that idea that quote and put it um
centered uh on the sculpture
so that
so that this idea
writ large in granite on fort worth's
main street
would be
a very obvious tribute to the president
and his ideas
and
and his
inspiration to us that our ideas are
important
and that and that we need great leaders
with great ideas
and and that those ideas do live on
our city's tour staff recently traveled
to fort worth texas to learn about its
richest